the reason that I've been able to grow
the way that I have is every video has
to tell a story with 10 million views a
month from shorts what kind of AD
Revenue are we talking about and what
have you had to do to actually build a
sustainable business out around your
YouTube channel that was one of the
topics that I've researched that had
high search volume and not as much
content being created and there was an
opportunity because there's not a lot of
guys doing that
YouTube shorts are blowing up right now
and getting over 50 billion views per
day across YouTube on the platform so
what are the tips what are the secrets
and what lessons do we need to know in
order to get started and grow with
YouTube shorts Our Guest today Ryan
Johnson is getting at this moment over
10 million views per month earning over
ten thousand dollars a month and
uploading around one YouTube short per
day and so we're going to be learning
his story and his strategies as he's
just a regular guy trying to get people
off of yo-yo diets teaching intermittent
fasting and has been blowing up lately
and so I'm excited to dive into this
episode of the think media podcast Ryan
welcome to the show uh thank you so much
for having me on Sean I'm super excited
to uh to talk with you today and have
been you know been with following think
media since I've been on YouTube coming
up on three years of September and I
think I joined VRA in October
the month after I started so I'm super
excited to be talking with you yeah
super grateful to have you on and I want
to get into of course your tips and
strategies but for a little bit of
context what is your how did you pick
your topic you know what is your your
topic you started three years ago how
did this all come about how did you get
started yeah so with a broad brushstroke
kind of I was in the Army was in the
Army for seven years got out of the army
started working a white collar job was
in that for about four years making good
money but I it was soul sucking I did
not like it I didn't it drained me to my
core I put on a lot of weight when I got
out of the army and one of the things
that I knew I needed to do was lose
weight get in shape and kind of Forge my
own path around that same time that I
started losing weight I've always been a
little bit of an entrepreneur a friend
of mine recommended that I look at
YouTube and documenting my journey
because I've been posting stuff on
Instagram so I looked at YouTube and was
like once I investigated it which is why
I found think media right away because I
knew that I wanted to build a business
and build something for myself so I
started posting my journey and that's
kind of how I got started was just you
know sharing my journey and I I picked
health and fitness because it's
something I've always been interested in
and I know if I wanted to have legs and
go for a while it had to be something I
was semi-passionate about so that's kind
of how I got started sharing sharing my
stuff on YouTube and I think I remember
when you posted a milestone of your 100
000 subscriber silver play button it
didn't happen as fast as you think but
it still happened pretty quick what was
the journey to a hundred thousand yeah
so it's funny Sean uh I think you and I
again I dove all in consumed everything
that I could about how to grow on
YouTube and
um you may or may not remember I think I
talked to you on one of your coffee with
candles uh I I was probably October or
November I was like Hey I want to be I
want to get to a hundred thousand in a
year and you told me you're like can you
get to a hundred thousand in a year
probably not but can you get there
absolutely and I hit it right around the
two year mark So Good call by you so I
was on YouTube for the first year I
think I got
um two or three thousand subscribers and
then really there was a period where I
went through a job transition
um and I had stopped uploading for a
little bit and I knew I needed to get
back and uploading I took about a month
and a half off and I started posting
YouTube shorts just to kind of keep
myself accountable
um and get some some kind of creative
juices flowing and then they started to
pick up and I started to see unlike any
other shorts that I had ever had that
got the you know the spike abuse and
then died
he's got I'm talking 800 views a day
which is a time when you're getting 40
views a day every day and then I was
like there's something to this and then
I started really diving into shorts
short form content last February 2022.
yeah I love this lesson because you know
a lot of people who listen to this they
are looking for like the one Magic
Bullet and what I think the truth is is
that there's actually multiple Magic
Bullets and the key is to find yours
shorts became the format that popped off
for you you had a lot of slow and steady
growth with long form but then you
really found your thing and we'll break
that down your methodology but for
others they're not getting as great of
results with shorts I'm sure they can
learn some of your strategies people
just want that one answer is it long
form or shorts both is it video
podcasting or shorter talking hit videos
both is it is it Vlog Style videos or
you know share the screen faceless both
it's it's all the above but it's finding
what works for you and you found YouTube
shorts to really start to grow describe
the format describe like because there's
so many different types of content we
can create what were those first
kind of like the title topic length
content
of your YouTube shorts that started to
break through so I took some of what I
learned in VRA and translated into my
shorts a little bit in that when I was
researching and
um I knew from the beginning that I kind
of wanted to do the what I eat in a day
because it matches with my Niche which
is weight loss and it's something people
are always interested in and it has a
lot of legs because you can you're
eating every day so there's a lot of
content there right
um so I knew I wanted to do the what I
eat in a day and looking back going
through VRA that was one of the topics
that I've researched that had high
search volume
and not as much content being created
and there was an opportunity because
there's not a lot of guys doing that so
I was like so that's the reason why I
started producing the what I eat in a
day content in my short form and then as
it started to take off
there are absolutely things I would say
after two months of posting I really
dialed in the tactics of it I think I
have a pretty
I think replicatable uh game plan or at
least how I approach my short form
content yeah we'd love to hear those
tactics yeah so what the thing that I
think about when it comes to shorts is
like you talk about understanding why
the viewer is coming there when a viewer
is going and you're answering a specific
question on a long-form video you need
to know what question they're asking and
then you answer it shorts why are people
coming to shorts they're coming to
shorts to be entertained first and
foremost like I notice some people in my
Niche the weight loss they're given
here's three tips on in short form but
unless you just happen to catch the one
person that's looking for that
because it's not appealing to a wide
audience in that first initial push it
doesn't get pushed further because it's
not appealing to a large audience so
first and foremost they have to be
entertaining because that's why the
viewer is in short form content kill
some time
and then I think the thing that I really
latched on to and the reason that I've
been able to grow the way that I have is
every video has to tell a story
a short story and my videos here's
everything I ate today and it has to be
stand alone
and then in that I drop little hints of
who I am in My overall Journey that
encourages people to come back because
if you watch one short you get what I
ate in that day and then a little you
know I'll dribble in some you know some
nuggets and information about weight
loss and stuff but then if you watch
them all together you get this long
story of here's a guy who has struggled
with his weight and learning how to just
live sustainably so when you watch them
all together I think that encourages
subscribers and encourages people to
keep watching because they want to know
how the story is going to play out and
you gained 9 000 subscribers just in the
last month so it's clearly working and
there's a Compound Effect there give us
kind of a preview of one of your shorts
I I love them they are Snappy and I do
notice you'll say you know I didn't eat
until intermittent fasting until such
and such time today and we this is where
we went my wife ordered a drink I tried
it it was pretty good I got this it was
delicious my daughter and and you know
and little kind of you're going going
through the narrative but there's also
those interesting kind of detours but
it's very entertaining it's very
interesting so what have you learned
about the assembly what do you think
about your Hooks and then how do you how
are you actually making these videos
like now that you've done this are you
just doing it on your phone just film it
all voice over later like what's kind of
the workflow for this yeah so the
workflow is something that absolutely
took time and I think the thing that was
important is just I tell people all the
time that ask me information or how to
get started with short form you just
gotta start right like you talk about
all the time like you can't see your
parked car you just gotta start going so
I film the stuff and what I used to do I
film everything on my phone I still do
that now I struggle I got a little bit
of ADHD and like to upload it from a
camera to the computer and wait for all
that stuff like I struggle with that so
I film and edit everything in my phone
just for workflow because any steps that
I have between filming and a finished
product just means that it's not going
to happen that's me personally so I film
and edit in my phone then when I started
it took me forever because I would film
every bit of food that I would have and
I would end the day with 30 minutes of
footage that I had cut to under a minute
and it took forever but as I do it in
the editing process I know what shots
I'm going to need so now for an entire
day of footage I'm going to get two and
a half minutes of footage so now I only
fill in two and a half minutes a day
because I know which shots I need I know
I need the shot of me opening the food
or the server setting the plate on the
table all that kind of stuff I know
which shots I need I edited in my phone
and now I write scripts after the fact
so I'll sit down I'll write a script
I'll record my voiceover of the script
and that's now my a-roll so then I can
sync what I'm saying with the b-roll
footage that I have whereas I used to
put all the b-roll together and then I
used to try to like say what was
happening as it was coming across the
screen and I was always playing catch-up
now I record my a-roll voice over and
then edit it in and actually I have an
editor that works for me full time now
this is my first hire oh that's amazing
and so at this point you're uploading
the footage from your phone to Dropbox
Google Drive Google Drive and so then
the editor takes it over you send them
you're also voice over audio file how do
you record that I record that on my
phone and then shot and I so I send them
one file it's all of the b-roll and then
black screen a-roll voice over so then
all over in one file for a given day and
it's only about two and a half uh
minutes of footage and then they edit it
down into less than a minute gotcha and
then
um before you hired an editor were you
just editing it yourself in in shot so I
edited everything myself in in shot and
it used to again take me 30 40 minutes a
day but now I don't do it now but if I
had to I could record edit voice over an
entire video start to finish in about 25
minutes yeah that's amazing and again
that comes with repetition yeah and I
want to encourage the listener like you
know now that you've been doing video
for three years I've been doing video
for 20 ironically and YouTube for 16.
like we recently went to Nashville and
uh when I go on different trips like I
know the shots to get and I actually
just go and and it also is kind of a
good way to not let social media or
filming on your phone take you out of
the moment
I just get the shot in the moment and
then set the phone down and then get the
leaving shot and then and then you're
still in the moment and then later when
you're just chilling on the couch
chilling in bed I edit my own little
social media voice over Instagram video
shorts and um and sometimes I'll write
out a little script and just read over
it and I was like so we recently took a
trip and these are a side strategy not
even a strategy more like just Recaps
that are kind of more for fun but I the
encouraging point I want to listen in
order to hear is that even hearing Ryan
break this down can be kind of
overwhelming but start messy start
before you're ready if it also he's like
30 minutes it takes me a day yeah if it
takes you a day when you're starting but
you will get faster and you also won't
overshoot huge mistake I've made too
hard drives full of footage and it slows
down the whole process but that's really
inspiring and
I want it's here because for The
Listener especially as you said
entertainment
you technically are an education Channel
or ultimately your business model but
you're tapping into entertainment
edutainment but if we looked at just
just that the listener might think well
how could that truly be though a
sustainable business of some kind how
could that really so how is it that you
make money and with 10 million views a
month from shorts predominantly I would
imagine what kind of AD Revenue are we
talking about and what have you had to
do to actually build a sustainable
business out around your YouTube channel
are you ready to start or grow your
YouTube channel do you feel stuck and
need help connecting the dots join this
free web class where you'll learn the
step-by-step playbook for YouTube
success we've helped thousands of
purpose-driven entrepreneurs just like
you grow their influence with video
register today for this exclusive
training at
thinkmasterclass.com yeah so I think one
of the things that I really took to
harden you you say it all the time you
know influence before income I was
always focused on making good videos
growing my audience before I tried to
cash like wait to cash the check because
you can tell I know there are
influencers that I watch and when they
pitch a product sometimes I'm going to
buy it because I I really really enjoy
what they do and it's like so with that
being said for the first two years I
didn't make that much on ad Revenue
you're talking you know fifty sixty
dollars a month in ad Revenue
um but I always approached it with I
want to set this up for the rest of my
life not for a get rich quick right
that's you're going to be disappointed
that way so the way that I have been
able to do it is I always knew that
there would be some business on the back
end I didn't know what that would look
like and a friend reached out to me we
were actually in VRA together and he was
doing online personal training and said
hey I think this may be an Avenue
that would work well for you I think it
fits well into what you're doing and I
think you'd be good at it so I looked
into and investigated doing online
personal training one-on-one coaching
and have been doing that since September
that's where a bulk of the revenue comes
from between 8 and 10 k a month now
again that's a great number and a lot of
people may hear that and think that's
incredible how do I start doing that but
realize that was built on
a year and a half two years of building
trust with my viewers so that the month
after I started that I was able to leave
my nine to five it didn't happen
overnight it was built slowly but that's
how I was able to translate it was
online coaching is what allows me to
sustain myself and my family and the
entertainment is just the start of the
funnel that's inspiring and that's the
bulk of it but you also now with your
influence and the content have also had
some a little bit of AD Revenue I
imagine still of course and that can
keep growing
um any Affiliates or brand sponsorships
yeah so
um ad Revenue right now I'm probably
averaging
um about between a thousand and fifteen
hundred a month that's shorts and long
form together a majority of it coming
from shorts probably about a thousand
now that they're doing the monetization
the way they are and getting about a
thousand to fifteen hundred from ad
revenue and averaging probably similar
in brand deals now brand deal is another
one that I want nothing more than to
partner with great Brands and work with
people that I think are going to support
what I believe in I get reached out
people reach out all the time saying hey
can we send you stuff and you do a video
I'm selective on who I work with and now
because I have the coaching I'm able to
set my price kind of where I want it to
be so that if I'm doing a brand deal it
makes sense for kind of both parties
yeah so you're very selective of brand
news how does a brand deal incorporate
like what was the last one is it in one
of the shorts Just One Day One
integration no so I'm doing most of my
brain deals are in the
um are in the long form content I think
Lumen was the last one I'm trying trying
a product right now one of the
continuous glucose monitors that video
I'm working with a behind the scenes
stuff for that I got that coming so
powerful in such I mean you embody your
purpose-driven entrepreneur uh our ethic
of of patience of playing the long game
aim of Legacy over currency of building
trust and then realizing that it the
interesting thing is you know business
trajectory wise they say the average
small business isn't profitable for 18
to 24 to 36 months so that early
investment in content in this case in
the crater economy of building influence
building trust adding value and you were
building it on a side hustle working a
nine to five like you mentioned that
seems like overnight success because you
launched coaching and then boom it was
full or you know but it was the what do
you not see overnight success takes a
year and a half two years as your uh
also putting in the work being
consistent and I am curious what your
tips are for like ultimately building a
community and connecting with your
audience because what I would imagine
especially with these daily shorts of
what I eat in a day you now have
characters you your family it's like a
Daily Show what's so nice is there's
constraints
um meaning it's only ever going to be a
minute or less
and people can come to expect it it
doesn't take too much from them but it's
a little touch point they can get to
know you every day and I'm sure many
thousands of people now are are kind of
like fans of your show you know that
it's very Community Based have you
noticed
similar commenters have has this led to
connections has this what have you
learned about really making connections
with your audience and building a
community Yeah a hundred percent I think
one of the things
um that I am very aware of is up until I
want to say it was
um March of last year right around the
I think 10 to 15 000 subscribers is when
I lost the ability to reply to every
comic
but up to that point every single
comment gets a reply and now
um I'm still at the point where I can
see just I can see most comments I try I
I block out time every day to reply to
comments and I understand that the
algorithm isn't a machine it's people
and like understand listen to those
comments reply back those comments
especially when you're getting started
whether it be shorts or long form every
time you reply to somebody and
especially in short form content with so
many different creators out there you
have just guaranteed yourself the next
10 uploads are getting viewed by that
person why would you like I remember
Thomas the Lauer is in my space he's got
three million subscribers I commented on
one of his videos this was I was I was
at thirty thousand so I was bigger he
replied back to my comment and I lost it
like I put up an Instagram story like
something with three billion subscribers
knows who I am that means a lot like
taking time to talk with people because
people or the algorithm if that makes
sense yeah that's a that's incredible
and I love your heart for your community
what is interesting is shorts has become
the thing that's working for you you
figured out a system around it you've
hired an editor but when it comes to
long form you actually have only
uploaded one video in the last month and
then every once in a while I thought
this was kind of a cool strategy as
you've grown is uh you also don't do
like a ton of live streams but it seems
like you do a live stream at certain
Milestones so what is your approach
right now on you on future long form
videos what's your intent there and is
that and how are you using YouTube live
streams yeah so live streams um I did
for every ten thousand or a hundred
thousand I did live stream q and A's
just time for that kind of immediate
feedback
um I think I really enjoy the live
streams I can also see the value
um in having that kind of content on
potentially a separate channel so I
think I've got a podcast you know in the
works I'll probably start some sort of
weight loss Focus podcast later in the
year and kind of keep the main YouTube
channel kind of more broad
um so which is why I've slowed down live
streams a little bit and as far as long
form content I am going to double down
on VRA now that we are through the move
and kind of settled in I'm going to
double down on VRA and get back to
answering specific questions in long
form because that's a great way for
people to find me to get questions
answered things like that because I also
see I have videos can you have diet soda
while fasting that I uploaded two and a
half years ago that's going to get me 50
views today without even thinking about
it yeah it's a great point and uh long
form when AdSense is not at this point
it's not even a need but man it can
really scale we've I was at a YouTuber
meet up in Vegas
um shorts is paying it seems anywhere
from two cents four we get six I saw
somebody I was getting nine cents
I think I'm getting about nine yeah
whereas uh we were comparing with other
creators some were getting two dollar
RPMs which is so much higher than nine
cents others were getting four I think
media we get seven and a half dollar RPM
at this exact moment which is it's crazy
I mean it's such a magnitude of order is
compared to shorts now we don't want any
think media podcast listeners to get
distracted or overly obsessed with
YouTube ad Revenue but even to think
about that aspect of course long form is
such a
it's nice to diversify your content and
it's such a kind of unshakable
foundation especially that Evergreen
content like there's absolutely the
value in it and I think one of the
things that I need to do is I I need to
get better at I have a short form I know
I know when I film a video which ones
are going to go viral and viral to me is
over a million views like if I post a
video I know it's getting between that
100 to 200 000 I know when I shoot one
that's going to be a million I can just
kind of tell it's a place with a
recognizable name like when I do what I
eat at Red Lobster right because because
people that don't know me see Red
Lobster and they're like you know that
surfing so I don't have the same
confidence in long form so it's
something that I need to to work on the
same way that I work on long form is to
get shorter hooks straight to the point
my my retention on long form is not what
it is on short form
I talk too much now you've got
um something that you're doing really
cool with the essentially YouTube shorts
you're creating to make even more money
from them off platform and I want to
hear about that in just a second but I
am curious uh now that you have been a
part of VRA what has kind of been your
experience interacting with VRA and
think media overall it's been great so I
think one of the things that I tell
people is like
um and I I work with people now on the
weight loss side of things and coaching
is like I tell people there's so much
value in accountability and coaching
um I'm a I'm a product of it because if
it wasn't for VRA all of the information
on how to grow a YouTube channel can be
found for free on YouTube
but it makes a difference in the thing
that I knew was because I was building
it as a side Hustle the thing that I
didn't have on my time on my side was
time so by getting the information like
succinct and if you give me a plan I can
execute it and that's kind of what that
provided for me is like you lay out the
plane and I can execute and I think the
thing that people need to work on is
their time frame even I needed to right
I want to do a hundred thousand in a
year if you can just say Hey listen I'm
gonna stick to the plan and just execute
it regardless of time
if you do not stop you cannot lose yeah
that's uh inspiring and it does great
things take time they take patience they
take hard work but it's awesome to see
your story and we actually I included uh
many of uh breakdowns of your videos and
tips in the brand new section of era the
YouTube shorts master class as well
because uh we love being in there as a
community in like a think tank of
exchanging great ideas and so as new
formats like YouTube shorts emerge
um you're inspiring our VRA fam and so
grateful for your
um just belief in us and your investment
in VRA and
um watching your catapulting growth but
as we land the plane what's so cool is
you're making these daily videos they're
not really YouTube specific YouTube
shorts is blowing up for you but you're
also uploading them elsewhere what's
happening there and you were mentioning
that uh that's even paying better than
in YouTube short yeah so
um I started uploading I have been a
YouTube first Creator I think from the
beginning I really do believe it's the
platform with the most legs and that's
where I invest in my time I started
uploading The Tick Tock actually last
summer my family and I were on vacation
in Gatlinburg and I am at the point now
where some few people will recognize me
in public hey I love your videos and I
think it's awesome and I tell everybody
I'm so small time but I really
appreciate it but some a few people came
up and said hey I love your tick tocks
and I was like I'm not on Tick Tock so
my first thought was you know somebody's
up up downloading my videos and just
uploading them to tick tock and then I
spent like two hours on Tick Tock
looking fortunately that wasn't the case
they were just saying tick tocks as
Anonymous with short form that's
interesting so but then I when I was
like all right well if I continue to
grow on YouTube like I imagine somebody
uploading to tick tock and saying
they're me is a possibility so I'm just
going to beat him to it so I started
uploading to tick tock Instagram
Facebook and have been doing that since
last year I think I'm at 63 000
followers on Tick Tock and I just for
seven months on Tick Tock I think I did
like 500 in there
uh Creator fund which was nothing like
and I'm just getting not as many views
on Tick Tock call it three to four
million views about half as I do on
YouTube but I am a few weeks into their
new Creator program and I'm getting
about one point a dollar fifty RPM
um so if things keep going the way they
are I could see two to four thousand
dollars a month just kind of depending
if I have some videos pop off from The
Tick Tock Creator fund that right there
is super encouraging it's also cool to
hear the hard data on the RPM because
that is significantly greater than
YouTube shorts RPM and
you're not creating different content
though you've already shot your footage
did your script recorded your voice over
sent it to your editor got the final out
asset and now you're just maximizing it
across platforms vertical video gives us
the opportunity to do this in a major
way has reels or Facebook seen any
decent growth so Facebook when I started
Facebook has slowed down I I went from
like zero to twenty thousand subscribers
in a matter of a month month and a half
but in the last three months I've picked
up another thousand followers on
Facebook so it seems like Facebook has
throttled it back I'm not sure what's
going on there or at least for me
personally
um and then Instagram has been
consistent growth and I think one of the
things that I'm going to do is
Instagram's where I'm going to focus my
coaching health and wellness so that
content is going to be a little
different more platform specific because
that's where I can DM people and kind of
talk about the weight loss side of
things whether Facebook's up or down I
think it probably is down a little bit
for everybody there was a golden few
months of reels Facebook reels there for
a while that we were shocked by as well
but we never cry about it because once
we have the vertical video asset it's
just a matter of distribution across
platforms and
um that's really inspiring to see
everything that you're doing well Ryan
you've added a ton of value today if
people want to check out what you're
doing of course to study I recommend
everybody go watch and check out the
show notes to look at how you're
creating shorts and how what people can
learn from the format and how they can
apply that to their content and perhaps
somebody is looking to get fit get
healthy maybe learn from you where can
people connect with you Ryan I would say
probably Instagram is the best way DMS
I'm at if with Ryan on Instagram Tick
Tock everywhere and then my email
address is ifwithryan gmail.com I love
talking YouTube I'm passionate about
this stuff
um and you know I just like talking with
people Ryan grateful for you and think
media podcast check out these show notes
so you can connect with Ryan and
anything else cool we mentioned in the
episode